Julie Linares is the executive director
of the human security center and a
principal consultant to the European
Parliament intergroup on religious
freedom Julie welcome to the show so
good to be here I'm really excited to
talk to you because I've been following
you on Twitter for probably three years
or so and you've really been ahead of
the curve on calling out Islamist
extremist terror or Islamic extremist
terror or jihadist terror or whatever
phrase you want to use y'all let you
break down some phrases you've been
ahead of it and one of the people that
when I see with the things that you
tweet I'm always like she gets it she
understands it so let's start what
brought you to this spot how did you get
involved in being one of the people that
studies this that talks about it that
consults about it well I I read my first
book on politics when I was 12 and I
know that probably makes me sound like a
complete piece I read my first book on
politics when I was 12 about the
conflict in Ireland about Northern
Ireland and I was interested in why
people were killing for their beliefs
and for their ideology and of course
Ireland was more about nationalist
terrorism rather than religious
terrorism I mean there was a religious
component in the sense that you have you
had the IRA on the one hand that was
Catholic and you had the UDA in the
other parameter Ally paramilitary and
organizations that were Protestant on
the other hands but anyway I mean that's
how I got in interested in in conflict
and white people were killing in
holiness and people for their beliefs
and then two years later of course 9/11
happens and I was 14 at the time I
remember it
acid as it was yesterday I wasn't in
school that day I was at home I was ill
I was sitting on the couch I was
watching random television and suddenly
this horrific images appeared on my
screen and obviously my first reaction
was this was a terrible terrible tragedy
in accident but the moment a second
plane
hit the towers I think everybody knew
that whatever it was and at a time
obviously we were still lacking the
rhetoric to describe what just happened
mhm I realized that this was a game
changer that the world would never be
the same again and that is true I mean
the world was never the same again after
9/11 in an obviously Afghanistan
happened and Iraq happened and when we
went into Iraq I was 16 at a time and I
think that was really the moment I would
describe as my awakening in the sense
that I realized we were not just
fighting the enemy from the outside but
also the enemy within and I'm not
talking about the people who opposed to
war perfectly legitimate reasons more of
victims
strategic reasons I'm talking about the
people who hijacked the anti-war
movement and who were happy to call
Judge George W Bush and Tony Blair war
criminals while at the same time turning
around and embracing people like Hamas a
terrorist organization that preaches
genocide against Jews and people like
George Galloway who was on record
praising Saddam Hussein's some courage
strings emphatic finishes yeah and that
was the moment when I realized guys we
really have a problem and we need to
talk about this yeah so I really want to
dive into that because it's it's so
related to everything we've been talking
about here this sort of moral confusion
that people seem to have and a lot of it
unfortunately does seem to be on the
left the rights got plenty of moral
confusion itself but yeah we seem to see
a lot of it on left that's interesting
so because you were young around the
time that 9/11 happened I'm a little
older than you I was in I lived in New
York City at the time and of course I
had studied politics before but of
course it was a defining moment for me
and for literally millions of people as
well so that so all that happens and
then when did you actually start working
in this field and really sort of talking
about this publicly and making that your
life's work well I actually started
writing a personal blog at the time that
the war in Iraq happened and I
about us a lot I mean that was the first
thing I really talked about publicly a
lot about the reasons why even though as
I said before I always had great respect
for the people who opposed the war for
perfectly legitimate reasons that I
however felt it was also a moral and
legitimate case for the war I mean look
at the torture chambers and the
concentration camps and genocide against
the Kurds i I think it was a former
Kurdish president who once said that
Iraq was a concentration camp above
ground above ground and a mass grave
beneath and that was true it was one of
the worst dictatorships on earth and
that's when I really got involved in
this debate and was exposed to divide a
pub leg and that was also the time
really when people started attacking me
for my views yeah so when when people
talk to you about the Iraq war now I
mean the the meme in America is that you
know had we not toppled George dub had
George W had we not topple George W Bush
had george w bush not not toppled Saddam
that ultimately had we not gone into
Iraq that that would have that Isis
wouldn't be here basically is the is the
idea of it and you know as I've talked
to some experts in this a lot of people
are saying well Saddam as you just said
was doing some pretty horrific things so
despite knowing now that there weren't
weapons of mass destruction or at least
that we never found them do you still in
your mind do you feel that that what we
did was still a moral case and what you
guys did is well and obviously you know
Tony Blair had something to do with it
yes I still believe I still believe
after everything that it was right to to
topple this regime and you know some of
some of the things that people were
saying why we shouldn't intervene like
at least Saddam Hussein contains Iran
for me really never was a moral argument
you cannot contain one dictatorship with
the theocratic regime and vice versa and
for the Kurd it was a liberation and we
look at Kurdistan today Iraqi Kurdistan
and a beacon of hope in the entire
region and I obviously I obviously
acknowledge that we we did something
terribly wrong
which led to bloodshed and
the dismantling of the Iraqi army
de-baathification and all of the big
things really I think were catastrophic
and I'm really happy to admit that but
it doesn't change defect for me that
this was a genocide or a dictator I mean
he committed a crime of all crimes
ninety-five percent of Kurdish villagers
were exposed to chemical weapons during
the campaign and that is still the
reason why I still believe after
everything that it was the right thing
to do yeah and that's not even to talk
about what he was doing to dissidents
and free thinkers and secularists and
other people yeah yeah so tell me a
little bit about the type of work that
you do now what what's actually the base
work that you're doing well we do
different things we work with government
governments of course we work with
non-governmental organizations we work
with the media we work with the public
so we do public outreach one of the
things that we're currently doing is we
are working with the European Parliament
intergroup on religious freedom and what
we're doing for them basically is a once
a year we are looking at the worst
violators of religious freedom across
the world everything at really all
continents from Latin America to Asia to
to to Africa and we we look at the
sources of persecution we look at why
religious minorities in that particular
country are targeted and by whom they
are targeted and what we can do to help
these people yeah all right so who's
doing most of the targeting well first
of all it is it is a phenomenon it
affects all countries across all
continents really and it also affects
all religions of course you have you
have for instance the brutal persecution
of Muslims in Burma by Buddhist
extremists and you have the persecution
of Muslims by Christian militia in the
Central African Republic or you have
you have the the persecution of
Christians by Hindu nationalists in
India but the vast majority of religious
persecution we see in the world today
has some kind of relation to the
religion of Islam whether it's by a
stage actor or a non-state actor okay so
I had a feeling that's what you were
gonna say so because we're we're the
good guys in this case and we try to
separate people from ideas how do you
guys when you're studying this and
you're learning about this how do you
separate what is done in the name of
religion in the name of doctrine versus
just the geopolitical realities on the
ground well I mean we look for instance
at at the law of the country and the
constitution of the country and what you
will find at many of these countries is
that the Constitution in itself already
discriminates against minorities so for
instance the president of the country
can only be Muslim and that is of course
not just something that that is purely
decided on religious grounds it's also a
strategic decision right I mean they
want you to keep power to themselves but
then you also have completely irrational
persecution of minorities who can't do
any harm whatsoever to the state because
there are tiny minorities and they are
deprived of all their eyes and that is
of course when it's no longer strategic
and that when it really comes down also
to religious doctrine and I'm talking
for instance about the Ahmadiyya Muslims
devised in Sunni Muslim states as often
to Shia again that is suppose related to
religion enter your politics are often
it's also a mixture of both and it's
very difficult to tell whether it is for
political or religious reasons that
people are being persecuted but yeah I
mean there definitely is a problem that
we have with religious inspired
persecution of minorities in the Muslim
world yeah so I know you do a lot of
work with and for the Kurds we've been
talking a bit about the Kurds here it's
an incredibly underreported story
especially
in the States are they the best example
of a persecuted minority because they're
a minority in at least four countries
they never got their state when the
whole thing was carved up and they're
basically treated incredibly poorly by
Turkey Iraq Iran and Syria so are they
really the best example for you when
you're talking about this kind of stuff
well you know I was joking a couple of
weeks ago that I should get myself a
t-shirt saying I supported the Kurds
before it became fashionable because now
obviously you know a lot of people talk
about them and don't get me wrong I'm
I'm really really pleased that people
are finally giving them the attention
and exposure that these wonderful and
open-minded and largely peaceful and
brave people deserve and yes I honestly
believe that probably since the
formation of the State of Israel in the
1940s that what we're seeing was
occurred the struggle for
self-determination is probably the most
promising democracy experiment in the
Middle East because look at what the
Kurds are doing I mean in rock you don't
if you if you take a rocky Kurdistan as
an example which is a senior economist
region in in the north of the country
they have their own president and Prime
Minister and Parliament and the
Peshmerga which is which is the army of
the Kurdistan region I mean they have
taken in hundreds of thousands of people
from Syria from Iraq persecuted by the
Islamic state hunted by the Assad regime
including tens of thousands of
Christians who otherwise would have been
slaughtered or at least enslaved they
were able to celebrate Easter in safety
and in peace and it's not just that they
are providing basic needs to these
people they are going a step further
they are actually trying to support the
right of these religious minorities and
last year the Kurdistan Regional erupted
something that I feel is absolutely
unique and historic they decided to give
to each of the minority minority
communities religious minority
communities in Iraqi Kurdistan their own
official
presentation so they all have their own
representatives now and not just it's
not just the Muslims and the Christians
know also the Jews and the buys and a
shattered - a box and and Ahmadiyya
Muslims who were persecuted all across
the Muslim world and you know these are
not just token appointments these guys
are really doing work the first Jewish
represented just comes back from from a
visit from Israel where he met with
lawmakers and I was trying to really
find ways to build bridges between
Israel and Kurdistan and this is
absolutely unique in that region and
it's fascinating if you think about
defect that just miles away from Erbil
whether whether Kurdish Parliament sits
the Islamic state is you know is is is
in place and that is of course the most
fundamental manifestation of radical
Islam yeah you know I had a few weeks
ago I had Bayan sami abdullah rahman
who's the the KRG rep to the united
states and we were talking about that
border and how close everything is and
it's really crazy because basically the
Kurds the Peshmerga they're fighting the
Isis on one side and then they're also
fighting Turkey on the other side and
Turkey is a NATO ally can you explain a
little bit of the complexity there
because it's really complex because
there are also Kurds in Turkey and they
have a political party and they're
trying to negotiate with Turkey it
doesn't sound like it's going that well
well you have to make a distinction
between the Kurds in Iraq and the Kurds
in Syria and the Turks and they put the
Kurds in Turkey and the Kurds in Iran
because they all have different goals
and they all have different
relationships with with Turkey as well
the relationship between the Kurdistan
Region of Iraq with Turkey's actually
not that bad if it's the problem with
the PKK in in Turkey
that is in well for many years now in
trapped in a brutal conflict with a
Turkish state and of course the PKK is
allied to the gpj in Syria which now
controls on the
the entire border with Turkey and Turkey
is bombing the the Kurds the same people
we are working with the u.s. is working
with to find the Islamic state so what
we are actually seeing is that the u.s.
net coalition if at war with itself yeah
so what what is that - because it seems
like this is now an open secret that
this is happening the Kurds are fighting
Isis on the ground they're basically the
only fighting force on the ground
fighting Isis and Turkey is bombing them
and we are a NATO ally with Turkey
so how is this secret being allowed it's
being it's out and we're not doing
anything about it what Europe needs the
cooperation of the Turkish state because
of the refugee crisis right turkey in
many ways it's a gateway from Syria to
Europe and they need gone to play play
along and that is one of the reasons why
so many governments in Europe hesitant
to criticize the Turkish government for
the way they're treating the Kurds
burden in our own country and also in
Syria yeah so Turkey basically is having
their cake and eating it too and that
they're letting the fighters in through
Europe right they come from Europe they
go through Turkey they go in and then
Turkey is then bombing the Kurds because
they're not thrilled with the Kurds so
it's good for them and then we have to
play ball with them because they're also
the buffer zone so really that's like
one of those cases where you can really
see how complex this stuff is yeah I
mean basically what you can say is that
Turkey is more afraid of a Kurdish stage
than it is of the Islamic state and
that's exactly I mean if you look at
their policy and the way they reacts in
the region I think that that's crystal
clear and we can't we can't really deny
that and I personally agree with you
that it's absolutely shameful that a
NATO partner is bombing the group of
people that is most efficient in
fighting the Islamic state now I'm not
condemning by any means the terrorist
attacks that we've seen in sight so if
you buy the PKK right nope no terrorism
is that
justified against anyone I I rejected
when he summit status doing that I
rejected when the IRA was doing that in
Northern Ireland and I reject that when
the PKK is doing that in Turkey but it's
more complex than just the PKK and a
Turkish state I mean this goes way
beyond Turkey just taking action against
the PKK they are really using this to
sort of justify an entire crackdown on
on the Kurds within Turkey and the Kurds
in Syria and this basically goes hunting
it it pant in hand with an increased all
three or Thorat arianism inside Turkey
if you look at the crackdown on the
media free speech activists this all
goes hand in hand it's not just the
curse that being targeted it's free
thinkers everybody who dares to
criticize President Erdogan yeah so I
want to back up to something that you
said about the Kurds a moment ago that
they've sent a representative to Israel
and I know that there are supposedly
some other sort of behind-the-scenes
relationships there but does that sort
of prove that at the end of the day
regardless of what religion people are
that really that having sort of the base
human freedom and respect for minorities
and things like that but that's what
will make these countries succeed or
fail it's not a coincidence that the
countries that seem to fail are the
least tolerant so that's a relationship
that should be nurtured further right
well absolutely and I think what you say
is absolutely true
the Kurds are the best example because
let's not forget they are Muslims the
vast majority of Kurds are Muslims and
yet they practice an Islam that is
inclusive and respectful to other people
and it is possible it's not it's not
mutually exclusive to be Muslim as as a
person and be be open-minded towards
others and the Kurds have a
long-standing history and culture of
Tolerance and peaceful coexistence so in
that way yes the Kurds really are the
best example and a beacon of hope in a
region that is otherwise drowning in in
blood and Maya right and it also it's a
beautiful thing because it shows that
religions can
always have to be their extremist parts
and that they're using their strategic
reasons in that area that they might
want to partner up with Israel on things
so it gets the religion out of it and it
gets some of the geopolitics out of it
yes it's quite interesting if you go to
Kurdistan and he talked to two people
about Israel and about America he
doesn't get this hostility that you get
in many Arab countries you know where
they perceive Israel and America as the
worst of everything and no again you get
a very different attitude in Kurdistan
where they are looking at Israel and
looking at America and they're looking
at our science and technology you know
leave aside politics for a moment look
at everything else
floral ISM that we have the freedoms
that we have freedom of speech everybody
you know has to right to do whatever
they say in want they Maya that they
they inspired to be like us not in the
sense that they were giving up their own
culture but having an open-minded view
of the world that is compatible with the
21st century